president trump's term in office was
marked by record-breaking staff turnover
including four chiefs of staff but one
constant in the west wing was kellyanne
conway she was the first woman to run a
winning presidential campaign and then
served as senior counselor to the
president for nearly his entire term she
was one of the most visible symbols of
the trump years as well and she's the
author of a new book it's called here's
the deal a memoir it's published by an
imprint of simon schuster which is a
division of cbs's parent company
paramount global and kellyanne joins us
now thank you very much for being here
my pleasure i really enjoyed the book uh
you have a lot to say uh someone said
that it's got more score settling than a
quentin tarantino movie and i think
that's true you take some whacks at
people uh which is different from how
you left the white house you said more
mama less drama
now you're back in the spotlight what
are you trying to accomplish here well
this is my memoir and
i people always ask me what's the story
behind the stories where did you come
from did you go up in a political
household
what do you see as the future for the 74
million trump voters who weren't at the
capitol on january 6 for example and i
wanted to go behind the scenes a little
bit but not with one of these tell all
and bore most i'm not speaking up now
because i didn't speak up then god knows
i spoke up then pretty much daily and
but i also i think that many women will
will relate to this book because
in most workplaces women sometimes feel
shoved to the side they feel
marginalized maybe by some of the other
women but especially some of the men
they work with and that happened to me
really early on tony i i was trying to
get my footing it was a rough first
couple of months and i think my big
decision at that time was do i slink
away and just go back home and say this
wasn't for me or do i realize hold my
head high with some dignity grace in
class try to get my footing work on
issues on my portfolio that are within
my wheelhouse and the whole time i had
the president's support which meant a
great deal because he was the guy on the
ballot he's the guy in charge and i'm
accustomed to working at a volume and
velocity that is very trump he's the guy
in charge you mentioned speaking up
while you're in office i have to ask you
about a story in the book in which you
describe yourself as maybe the first
person in the president's inner circle
to tell him he lost in 2020. the
president took to truth social his
social media platform and says that's
not true didn't happen otherwise he
would have locked you out we've got the
whole long
non-tweet alternative tweet there um
what do you say to the president uh
contesting your version no what exactly
he said he wouldn't have dealt with you
any longer she would have been wrong and
you could go back with your crazy
husband yes she didn't just say you know
no she's not telling the truth so the
that excerpt in the book really speaks
to the president coming up short before
the december 14th certification by the
electors and i had talked to the
president several many times between the
elect election day and december 14th and
saying you have every right to deal with
al gore did what others have done which
is if you're going to go find evidence
of malfeasance the shenanigans a
theft for all you have every right to do
that with your legal team and present it
and we all know what happened they they
tried they presented it the election was
certified for
biden harris but other people had
another idea to blow past december 14th
and look at january 6 as another
alternative way and i think look it's
very simple for me i've always had a
great relationship with president trump
and i go on and on in the book of how
protective he was of me my family he was
a great girl boss we have five you know
high ranking women with 19 kids highest
ranking we had 19 kids 12 daughters
seven sons ages two to 16 at this moment
when i'm looking up at a meeting at 8 20
in the morning we're all there but i
wanted to say this
that if president trump wants to be
president again it's a very simple path
he should just run against joe biden but
kellyanne i do want to ask because
you're painting a very rosy picture also
we walked away from the key question
here because did you tell the president
that he failed on november 3rd because
he says he didn't i told him that they
did not that with december 14th coming
up it didn't look like they had produced
the evidence needed to stop the
certification of the election which had
happened now there's another day that
you certify january 6th and in fairness
there are democrats in congress as we
sit here who have never voted to certify
a republican presidential election in
this century they didn't do it anymore
we're talking about your memoir and the
stories in your book yes and i did i did
and it broke my heart i wish you were
still the president because what's
happening i do yes i do i do gail
because um i think this man-made
disaster of biden harris has hurt a lot
of people we have infants looking for
baby formula we have five dollar gas
prices okay but let's just focus on
trump for a second and while you were
there because you say you can hold your
head high did you always feel that way
because i think the the consensus about
kellyanne conway was you're very good at
your job no question but you seem to
have to do a lot of spinning for a
president who was very fluid with the
truth and i i think that's putting it
very diplomatically you have former
administration officials john kelly
general mattis general barr
who say trump is
unqualified unfit for office and even
detached from reality
how does that square with what you see
as somebody who is if he wants to run
again he should well i served with each
of those men and i respect them for
their public service but they're saying
it now they didn't say it then john
kelly is the longest serving chief of
staff to president trump that's just a
fact what's your point about that well
my point is also what i saw in president
trump is somebody who was the wish
fulfillment of voters what they told
pollsters like me for decades i want
somebody with a ton of experience who's
not connected to washington who's not a
politician thinking well who's that and
here he came pre-verified as a tv star
with the number one show
obviously a successful businessman and
job creator what i think was less
charming gail is that some of the people
around him had no washington experience
i think it was determinative that donald
trump didn't have any i think that's
been killing this that's the thing okay
that's what they're saying but even your
own husband this is i think fascinates
so many people your own husband seemed
to have turned on his mind
changed his mind are totally turned i
mean you're right in the book of the man
you thought had your back ended up
stabbing you in the back you're in the
white house you're the white house
senior adviser and your own husband is
saying very disparaging things isn't
that unfortunate isn't that very sad
because george does not for you i think
that's very unfortunate thank you very
much gail i really appreciate it again i
think women can relate to that but this
was next level and i'll say this george
conway's vows are not to donald trump he
doesn't owe loyalty or fealty to a
political party or a certain president
um that was to me and to honor and
cherish and george and i have a lot of
things in common we've been married for
two decades we have four children
together another thing we have in common
is we both accepted very big jobs from
president trump yeah george took that
job started interviewing staff and then
changed his mind about president trump
he's welcome to do that but it was very
unlike george to be so publicly
bombastic he was always proud and how
did you handle that when you when you
went home i mean you write in the book
democracy will survive america will
survive not sure george conway and i
will survive it's very sad to me as we
sit here today did you all survive i'm
curious say it again as you sit here
today did you and did your marriage
survive well here we are i'm at the
shore this weekend with the kids lots of
kids they're with their friends but you
know yeah divorce people i'm going to go
but look you know sure i wish it was so
it's not someone like george to not take
action on something that means something
to him if it means that much to him i
think we should have gone to couples
counseling as ivanka trump put in her
post-it no and i think we all do what we
want with our time and i my objection is
that he spends his time doing that he's
welcome to do that but um look it's also
why wasn't i given the courtesy of being
told ahead of time tomorrow my op-ed
george george tell me my op-ed's going
to be in the new york times the
washington post i'm in the lincoln
project now we're going to have a new ad
yeah skewing your boss it was meant to
make me uncomfortable and let's face it
i quantify it in the book he was known
as kellyanne conway's husband
mostly described that way that's very
unusual i want to agree but but
curious knowing what you know now with
the sacrifices made within your own
family with with your with your kids
with your husband
you're not wearing a ring now as we as
we sit here he doesn't either would you
do it all again i would definitely serve
the country again and i think that the
trump pence administration had great
accomplishments for this country and
many measures energy independence the
economy that was humming even at the
beginning of the coronavirus cove and
getting those hundred thousand
ventilators making sure you want to work
for the president again ppe i would love
to work in the white house i would love
to serve at some level because white
house for the president president trump
well i would love to get rid of biden
and harris i think they've not done well
if you look at the polls you look at the
huge nbc news report today they're not
doing well i mean even are you and
george conway we're running out of time
kellyanne you're not going to talk to
your questions
well and thank you for reading this i
have many questions
it's a big book you said is it a
doorstop or a showstopper i think i
think it's both haley and conway thank
you very much here's the deal it's on
sale right now
give it a read it is worth your time